هدمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بنايه
سكنيه تقطنها سبع عائلات فلسطينيه في
ضاحيه سلوان بالقدس الشرقيه المحتله وجاءت
عمليه الهدم بحجه البناء دون ترخيص وقد
حصلت قوه الاحتلال محيطه منطقه الهدم
واغلقت الطرقات لمنع الفلسطينيين من
الوصول الى الموقع وتؤوي الشقق المكونه
المكونه للبنايه 50 مواطنا من عائله
الحسين واكدت العائله ان البناء تم تشييده
قبل اربعين عاما وانها تلقت امر الهدم عام
2018 وتوجهت الى المحاكم الاسرائيليه
للحيلوله دون تنفيذ القرار لكن دون جدوى
معنى من بلده سلوان في القدس الشرقيه
مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم احمد اذا الان
سبع عائلات دون ماوى بعد هدم هذه البنايه
ضعنا في الجو العام هناك
نعم سهام سبعه عائلات اكثر قرابه سبعين
شخص كانوا يسكنونها في هذا المبنى السكني
الذي تشاهدونه انقاضه هنا هذا ما تبقى من
هذا المبنى السكني الذي كان 6 شقق
سكنيه وياوي سبعه عائلات باتوا الان بلا
ماوى بعد ان اخبرتهم السلطات الاسرائيليه
صباح اليوم بين الهدم سيتم
بعد خمس سنوات من تلقيهم اخطارا او من قبل
السلطات الاسرائيليه بان منزلهم سيتم هجمه
لعدم الترخيص لكنهم منذ ان اشتروا هذا
المبنى السكني عام 2006 حاولوا بشتى الطرق
استصدار تراخيص
لجعل هذا المبنى قانوني لكن السلطات
الاسرائيليه رفضت مرارا وتكرارا لاسباب
عديده الان تشاهدون هذه هي جزء من
العائلات التي كانت تقطن في هذا المبنى
تشاهدونهم يفترشون الارض بعد ان ذهب
ذه ساكنهم وهي وهم ضحايا للسياسه
اسرائيليه منذ عقود تعاقب الفلسطينيين
بهرم منازلهم كجزء من العقاب كما ذكرت او
تقوم بالهدم بناء على
بناء على حجج عديده في مسعى اسرائيل كما
هو معروف لتهويل القدس وتشريد الفلسطينيين
الساكنه في القدس الشرقيه اكثر من 96 مبنى
سكنيا تم هدمه منذ بدايه العام في القدس
الشرقيه وحدها سبعه منها في هذا الحي حيث
سلوان
اكثر من 250
فلس تم تشريدهم بعد هدم هذه المنازل رغم
التعهد الاسرائيلي لحلفاءها الدوليين
وبالاخص الولايات المتحده بانها ستوقف
عمليات الهدم بدايه مطلع العام وذلك في
جزء كجزء من التزامها بالمسعى الامريكي
لتخفيض التصعيد لان لان السلطات
الاسرائيليه عفوا مستمره بهذه السياسه
ومستمره بتحميل الفلسطينيين معاناه فوق ما
فوق معاناه تشريدهم من بيوتهم وممتلكاتهم
سهام
شكرا الجزيره كنت معنا من بلده سلوان في
القدس الشرقيه المحتله